[Musique]
et c'est une maladie infectieuse ou
maladie très dangereuse pour les gens
mais matt est simple on doit savoir que
ici au sénégal
la plupart des gens sont des pauvres
sont tous des pauvres déjà de bien dans
les maisons pour toi moi ça c'est tout
moi je ne suis pas d'accord avec ça ce
qu'ont fait les gens je suis pas
d'accord je ne suis pas d'accord
mais même ça doit aider aussi les gens
écouter les gens aider les gens
[Musique]
à compter de ce jour il sera prononcé la
levée des restrictions de transports
c'est l'étendue du territoire national
avec le maintien du couvre-feu de 23h à
5h du matin le gouvernement regrette
toutefois les manifs et sasha reconnu
ces dernières 48 heures qu'il reconnaît
l'arrestation de plus de 200 personnes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant
m
pour